and this brings us to cpac the
conservative political action conference
has been going on for a long time the
american conservative union
uh puts it on it's always a very fun
event i went last year where we did a
verdict episode with
ted cruz a lot of i've been going for
years and years i think i went to my
first cpac 10 years ago
cpac's title this year is america
uncanceled
fighting back against cancel culture and
fair enough
but they just found out that one of
their speakers this guy
young pharaoh who i don't know what he
does
but i don't know he's like some pop
culture guy or something
young pharaoh has said some very
offensive things about jews
and other people so what does cpac do
they cancel them from their roster
now cpac is being called hypocrites
because they're indulging in cancer
culture
i don't think cpac is being hypocritical
at all i think it is the
shallowest stupidest read of the term
cancel culture
to suggest that you can never have any
standards at all
i think it is that that kind of a
shallow interpretation
that has allowed political correctness
to advance
for decades and decades and actually if
you
believe the argument of my book it's
been advancing for about a century
there is nothing conservative about
removing all the guard rails think about
it like a country
think about it just like a country a
country needs borders that was that was
what merit garland
finally acknowledged that joe biden he
says look he believes that it's a
country that has borders
all countries have borders and what
borders mean is some people are in and
some people
are out a certain
area defines what the country is and
things outside that area
that's not the country the same thing is
true in our philosophy
do you think if cpac invited someone to
speak forget about you know
anti-jewish comments let's make it even
more basic than that
some guy gets invited to speak at cpac
and then in between the time he gets
invited in the time he speaks
he becomes a liberal democrat and he
wants to give a speech on how great aoc
is and how he can't wait to vote for joe
biden's re-election or better yet kamala
harris
do you think cpac has an obligation
you know in its opposition to cancel
culture and obligation to put that guy
on stage no of course not
if anything cpac has an obligation to
take that guy off the roster
because this is the conservative
political action conference and
conservatism
stands for something we're debating what
that stands for
but but we we absolutely must define it
and actually
the unwillingness the cowardly
unwillingness to define
what conservatives stand for is what has
made us lose
many many many times over the past
several decades
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content out there
[Music]
you